time is a dimension just like length
breadth or height but whereas we can
move in any direction in those other
three dimensions we can only move in one
direction of time forward relentlessly
why why can't we ever move backwards in
time for a long while scientists can
come up with a convincing explanation
below the physics you see work fine
whether you're going forwards or
backwards in time their answer finally
came from an unexpected place steam
engines at the start of the Industrial
Revolution engineers were trying to
understand how to make steam engines
more efficient in examining how all that
heat and energy moved around an engine
they developed a whole new branch of
science which they called appropriately
thermodynamics and it turned out that
thermodynamics could explain the
behavior of a lot more than just steam
engines in particular the second law of
thermodynamics helps us to understand
why things happen in the order that they
do a cup smashes on the floor for
example and spills out all its contents
now we inherently know that that process
is irreversible the cups smash things
have a way of disorganizing themselves
but they're not so good at reorganizing
themselves and the second law of
thermodynamics tells us why
another way of looking at it is in terms
over messiness a cup is tidy a smashed
cup is messy the word for this in
physics is entropy more entropy there
isn't a place the more disordered messy
and useless it is here's what the second
law of thermodynamics looks like this S
represents entropy and this D is a
mathematical way of representing change
so D s simply means a change in entropy
now if you look at this equation from
left to right what it says is the
entropy of the system always has to
increase when a cup smashes or a freezer
defrost that's fine according to the
second law of thermodynamics because the
entropy of those things increases but if
you expect melted ice to reassemble
you're expecting entropy to fall and
that would break the second law that's a
no-no the second law tells us what order
things can happen in the universe it
gives us a clear direction for the flow
of what we call time forward time simply
can't flow any other way because that
will decrease entropy and break the
second law but where is the relentless
march of time taking us the entropy of
the universe the disorder is always
increasing always at some point in the
far future this means that our entire
universe will be in a state of total
disorder a state of maximum entropy
scientists call it the heat death this
is how our universe will end but don't
worry this bleak fate won't come upon us
anytime soon the universe will have to
wait trillions and trillions and
trillions more years by which time of
course there'll be no humans left to see
how time and entropy are ravaged our
universe
[Music]